Tomlinson: Hi, my name's
Jason Tomlinson.
I'm an engineering manager
at Hands-On Mobile.
I'm here today
to talk to you
about an Android application
I've written
which uses the accelerometer
feature of the platform.
The game is called "Amazed."
The whole idea of the game
is to navigate a marble
through the maze
by tilting the device
in various directions.
Whatever direction
you tilt the device,
the marble will follow
the same path.
You have to try
and navigate the marble
to the light blue area,
which will then
take you to the next level.
As you progress through
the ten levels of the game,
each level gets
progressively harder,
until you
get to Level Ten
which is almost impossible.
So that's the game.
You can find it
open-sourced
on the Apps for Android
project.
While it is only
a simple technical demo,
I built it to play around
with the accelerometer feature
of the Android platform.
It was born from the fact
that I was working
on "Guitar Hero: World Tour"
which we're bringing
to the Android platform,
fully leveraging
all the specific features
including multiplayer
battle mode,
so you and your friends
can play against each other
in real time.